INTRO:
In the past 2 years, the money supply has
increased from $15.5 trillion to $21.8 trillion.
This has caused asset valuations to go parabolic
and inflation to go through the roof.
We’re seeing CPI readings come in at over
8% and gas prices in some parts of the country
have soared past $6 per gallon.
Despite all these red flags, for the longest
time, the Federal Reserve was insisting that
inflation was simply transitory, and that
it was just a matter of time until prices
stabilized.
While the market was somewhat skeptical of
this idea, it gave the fed some credit until
the fed rugpulled everyone and became extremely
hawkish.
Eversince then, the stock market has gotten
crushed with many mega tech companies falling
50, 60, 70% from their all time highs.
Meanwhile, the housing market is starting
to show its first signs of weakness with new
home sales dropping off substantially.
Considering all this, you would expect for
the dollar to currently be performing a cliff
dive manuever, and this is what’s happening
from a nominal perspective.
However, from a relative perspective, the
dollar is actually skyrocketing.
Wait wait wait wait, what am I even talking
about.
Well, I’m talking about the dollar index
or ticker symbol DXY.
If you’re not familiar with the dollar index,
it seeks to measure the strength of the US
dollar relative to a basket of foreign currencies.
And over the past 12 months, the DXY has mooned
to multi year highs.
And if you really want to get technical with
it, you’ll see that the DXY has actually
reached a slightly higher level than the peaks
of the past several years.
In fact, the last time the DXY was this higher
than this way back in December of 2002 or
nearly 20 years ago.
And if you don’t believe this index, then
just take a look at foreign conversion rates.
The Euro, for example, has fallen to multi
years lows against the dollar, and it’s
nearly at 1 dollar per euro.
Similarly, the British pound is also testing
multi year lows against the dollar, and the
last time the pound was sizeably weaker than
this was way back in 1985.
Clearly, while the US dollar is getting crushed
in terms of buying power, it’s actually
gaining dominance on the world currencies,
so what in the world is going on with the
dollar?
SUPPLY & DEMAND:
Starting with the biggest culprit, we have
supply and demand.
Though we often like to think of currencies
as a stable medium of exchange during regular
times, currencies are actually subject to
all of the same supply and demand characteristics
that affect something like the stock market.
Currencies simply have extremely low volatility
during regular times.
However, with ground breaking events like
printing trillions of dollars followed up
by suddenly raising interest rates, it’s
not surprising that even currencies are experiencing
abnormally high volatility.
Also, it’s not just the US who has been
engaging in such activities either.
Most of the world’s central banks have engaged
in very similar monetary polcies.
Take the European Central bank or the ECB
for example.
Since the pandemic started, they have also
pumped trillions of dollars euros into the
market.
Now, this isn’t quite as high as the US
in terms of dollars, but the thing to note
is that relative to economic metrics, the
money printing of other central banks are
just as high if not higher.
For example, the total GDP of all the Europeon
Union countries that use the Euro is $12.23
trillion.
While this is an extremely respectable figure,
it’s only about 60% of the United State’s
$20.94 trillion GDP.
Now, this isn’t an exact science by any
means, but this leads us to believe the the
ECB cannot print more than 60% of the dollars
printed by the US if they want to maintain
the exchange rate between the two currencies.
This same principle applies to smaller economies
as well.
The UK, for example, has a GDP of $2.7 trillion
which a little more than an eighth of the
US.
Given that the US has increased their money
supply by about $6.3 trillion, this means
that the UK could increase their money supply
by about $800 billion.
However, the UK has surpassed this threshold
by quite a bit.
So far, the UK has printed 895 billion pounds.
If we use the average pound to dollar conversion
rate in 2021 of 1.3757, we’ll see that this
money printing correlates to $1.231 trillion
which is over 50% higher than what they should’ve
theoretically printed.
If you look into the money printing of some
of the other leading nations, you’ll see
that they have fallen into the same trap of
printing more money than the US on a relative
basis.
On top of this, many of these countries aren’t
pulling back nearly as aggressively as the
US currently is.
And for obvious reasons, this has led to the
US dollar performing quite well in relation
to these foreign currencies.
EXTREME UNCERTAINTY:
Aside from fundamental supply and demand factors,
external fears have also influenced the dollar’s
recent parabolic move.
One of the top concerns for most investors
right now is how hawkish the Fed will be over
the next couple of months.
Currently, there are rumors floating around
that the Fed will hike rates by 0.75 basis
point not once but twice in both June and
July.
Whether this ends up happening or not, the
stock market has already preemptively corrected
for this.
Some would even argue that it has overcorrected
Regardless of whether the market sell of is
justified or not though, in the end, significant
amounts of capital have left the stock market.
By now, I’m sure most of you guys have seen
my videos on how several companies have been
shedding hundreds of billions of dollars in
market cap.
And while a lot of this value just evaporates
away, the primary place the remaining capital
is going is cash which is significantly driving
up the demand for US dollars.
Something else to note is that it’s only
the stock market that has acted preemptively,
the real estate market is yet to react.
If the rumors regarding the fed end up coming
true, the Fed would have raised interest rates
by 2% within a matter of 6 months.
Theoretically, home prices should drop 10%
for every 1% interest rates go up.
And given that home prices have just started
to level off, this could mean that they have
a rough 6 to 12 months ahead.
And once again were does all the cash leaving
the real estate market go, it goes to cash
which further increases demand for the dollar
in the short term.
Also, it’s not just people pulling back
on investments either.
Some of the largest companies in the world
will substantially pull back as well.
Now of course, Elon is out there buying Twitter,
but he’s an anomaly.
Instead, take a look at someone like Amazon.
Amazon just posted their first quarterly loss
in 7 years due to losses from Rivian, increasing
supply chain costs, and slowing revenue growth.
Do you really think Amazon is going to go
out and make big acquisitions anytime soon?
Probably not.
The more likely scenario is that they’re
going to hoard cash and prepare for a market
downturn.
Similarly, Apple is warning investors that
sales could drop by as much as $8 billion
within the coming months.
Pair this with rumors that the iPhone 14 will
be even more underwhelming than usual, and
I don’t its very likely that Apple will
be making any big moves anytime soon.
And that’s just Apple and Amazon.
I don’t even think I need to discuss the
states of PayPal, Netflix, and Facebook.
Now, none of this is to say that a market
crash is even around the corner in the first
place.
After all, crashes don’t happen when everyone
is expecting it.
But, the key is that everyone from retail
investors and small businesses to hedge funds
and mega cap companies are expecting it and
consequently preparing for it.
And all of this uncertainty is giving the
US dollar significant buying pressure.
NO INFLATION HEDGING:
During times of high inflation, one of first
things investors do is move a significant
portion of their wealth in inflation hedges.
Historically, the most popular inflation hedge
has been gold.
For example, in the 1970s, when the US was
experiencing double digit inflation rates,
the price of gold went vertical.
Between 1976 and 1980, the price of gold went
from $100 per ounce to $875 per ounce.
Today, inflation is once again almost in double
digit territory; however, people haven’t
really been flocking towards gold.
In fact, gold hasn’t really moved since
July of 2020.
Not to mention, it’s not like this are new
levels for gold either.
In fact, gold reached these same levels way
back in 2011.
If we take a look at silver, the story is
even bleaker.
Between 1976 and 1980, silver grew over 10x
from $3.80 per ounce to $48.34 per ounce.
Today, however, like Gold, Silver hasn’t
moved since July of 2020.
What makes silver even worse though is that
it’s literally 50% lower today than it was
at the peak of 1980.
Of course, many Silver bulls would suggest
that this is precisely why Silver is such
a good investment and that it’s extremely
undervalued currently.
Now, they could be absolustely right and Silver
may be on the cusp of a historic rally, but
as of right now, Silver nor Gold has really
done much meaning that very little cash has
flowed into these inflation hedges.
It’s not just historic inflation hedges
that aren’t getting any love either.
The best example of this is Bitcoin.
Many Bitcoin bulls suggest that that Bitcoin
is the new gold and that its the perfect inflation
hedge given that it’s supply is capped at
21 million coins.
Ethereum bulls would argue that Ether is an
even greater inflation hedge than Bitcoin
given that Ether is actually headed towards
becoming a deflationary cryptocurrency.
Yet, despite all this, neither Bitcoin nor
Ethereum are rallying substantially.
In fact, they’re both down nearly 50%.
Now, I gotta say, even though Bitcoin and
Ethereum are by no means making new all time
highs, they’ve actually been holding up
extremely well given that they’re down less
than companies like Netflix and PayPal.
With that being said though, we have yet to
see any meaningful move towards inflation
hedges meaning that all the money people are
cashing out of the stock market and the bond
market is just staying cash.
And this is keeping demand for the dollar
quite high.
STATE OF THE DOLLAR:
At the end of the day, the main takeaway from
all of this is that despite all of the Fed’s
quantitative easing, the dollar is actually
still holding up extremely strong from a global
perspective.
Now, this has nothing to do with inflation
or prices.
After all, if the US has a 10% inflation rate
while the rest of the world has a 15% inflation
rate, the dollar would still be performing
extremely well in relation.
The main factors driving forward the dollar
right now is enormous amounts of money printing
from other countries, extreme uncertainty
in the market regarding the fed, and very
little inflation hedging take place.
Looking forward, whether this momentum will
continue or not comes down to the Feds stance
over the next couple months and whether inflation
starts to cool down substantially.
If inflation cools down and the Fed backs
off, then it’s very possible that we enter
a risk on market once again.
And during a risk on market, people don’t
hold cash.
Rather, they invest it all into assets which
will drive down demand for the dollar.
This could cause the DXY to stagnate or even
start trending down.
On the other hand, if inflation continues
to get worse and the Fed becomes more hawkish,
the market might become even more risk off
causing the dollar to reach levels that it
hasn’t seen in decades, but we’ll just
have to wait and see.
Do you guys think the DXY is going up or down?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re hoping that
inflation cools off sooner rather than later.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.